[Musique]
maxime guény merci dos alors maxime dit
sa vérité plutôt la vérité on en est où
avec kelly alors ils partaient les
dîners bas étaient allés grandiose c'est
ça s'est passé deux heures à rire enfin
ces deux ans oui d'ailleurs tous
devraient en prendre de la graine parce
que je crois que la sphère fonctionne
plutôt bien
ah oui elle est très amicalement
sympathique qu'un qu'est-ce que ça je
pense que c'est la salade césar qui nous
a mis en joie
c'est après une salade césar way est
aujourd'hui très enfants parce que elle
s'est approchée de moi pour le plaisir
du coeur et le plaisir des yeux
aulas
[Applaudissements]
c'est notre musique et notre humeur en
musique le meur de qui de maxime et moi
non allez ici ça va partir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui chez vous il dit parce que je reçois
plein de sms de potes qui me dit non mes
frères me dis pas qu'il va la paix
choquant
je ne soit pas plein de mecs vous dise à
l'effet que nous c'est pas possible
jean michel mézy personnes y croient
mais je crois que kelly qu'anne-marie
une petite tumeur d'ailleurs
[Musique]
ben voila je crois qu'elle a choisi son
camp et apparemment jean michel vous
n'êtes pas dans ses plans mais du tout
du tout le public ne se trompe pas lui à
morteau ce week end je te manger des
saucisses à morteau forme à ce que tous
les morts tauziat et bien tout le monde
m'a dit quand est ce que tu fais des
shows avec kelly ils voient bien qu'ils
aient un truc entre nous et ils veulent
nous voir ensemble ils m'ont pas parlé
de maximy d'accord a vaillamment
retourner à sa mort me sens ridicule
tous les deux en tout cas merci vous des
travaillistes
tu prends pas de médicaments pas qu'il y
aura les deux pourquoi vous voulez
trouver des règles parce que j'espère
que kelly et d'autres choix dans la vie
quand même j'adore
oui la sphère est dans le sac ça qu'il y
bien sûr c'était bien je sais bien c'est
qu'on nous c'est comme ça mais c'est
comme le troisième jour de ski